[Musique]
drôle d'ambiance après le passage de la
tempête sur la route départementale 48
qui mène à salazie le temps est suspendu
et en arrière fond la rivière gronde t
pendant à quoi alors oui les conditions
qui n'arrêtent pas jean françois grondin
le responsable de brigades de lutter est
gère toutes les équipes réparties sur le
cirque
il est aux petits soins sur cette route
depuis plus de 19 ans
nous on a travaillé la nuit suite à les
interventions qu'ils avaient de nuit
jusqu'à à peu près 1h30 du matin
et du goût
ce matin on a rempli de bonheur béat
c'était oman quand on était sûr sur la
route avec un inspection du réseau les
vingt neuf kilomètres de la rd48 tout
comme les 18 km de la rd 52 sont marqués
par les conditions climatiques mais ici
l'urgent est de libérer le passage je
vous faut tirer un peu bande branchies
jeunes sur la route
et puis tout le monde peut voir passer
bien et puis sans gêner personne nulle
est là pour rendre service aux
populations déjà pas mal et puis bon
c'est notre boulot c'est bien
ça ça me tire jason
un peu plus haut en direction d' il est
avide hot les éboulis s'enchaînent tous
les problèmes doivent être résolus
instantanément la journée est loin
d'être terminée on est comme ça on est
là on a des entreprises qui est sucré
temps avec nous donc on fait les
interventions soit d'urgence soit la
journée quand ils sont sur le réseau on
fait de notre mieux quoi voilà quoi que
tous les gens tout le monde soit content
ça comme ça ce jour là les vingt agents
du département mobilisés sous la pluie
ont permis aux 7000 habitants de salazie
de commencer dès leur réveil une
activité normale
[Musique]